بعد ارسال دبابات غربيه الى اوكرانيا الان
تعلن بولندا عن ارسال طائرات مقاتله من
طراز ميغ تسعه وعشرون سابقه تشكل نقله
نوعيه في طبيعه الدعم العسكري المقدم الى
اوكرانيا كخطوه الاولى سننقل الى اوكرانيا
في الايام المقبله اربع طائرات من طراز 29
تعمل بكامل طاقتها اما الطائرات الاخرى
التي تخضع حاليا للصيانه والتجهيز فسيتم
ارسالها اتباعا يعرف الطيارون الاوكرانيون
التعامل جيدا مع طائرات ميجستوفيتيه الصنع
فقد كان لدى القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه 36
قطعه منها في بدايه الحرب بحسب مختصين
سيكون لهذه الطائرات دور في حمايه الاجواء
الاوكرانيه من الطائرات الروسيه وفي اسقاط
صواريخ كروز اوكرانيا ممنونه من المبادره
البولنديه لكنها لم تفقد الامل بالحصول
على مقاتلات امريكيه لن تحل طائرات ميج
جميع المشاكل نحتاج الى طائرات اف 16 الى
الان ترفض واشنطن وبرلين تلبيه طلب كييف
بالحصول على طائرات مقاتله ويعود هذا
الرفض الغربي الى عدم الرغبه في استفزاز
موسكو فبعكس الدبابات يمكن للطائرات ان
تشكل تهديدا على الاراضي الروسيه ويقول
الغربيون ان الطائرات المصنعه في بلدان
حلف الناتو تتطلب تدريب الطيارين
الاوكرانيين كما ان الطائرات تحتاج الى
ارسال قدرات اضافيه تتعلق بالتزويد
بالوقود والصيانه والتسلح